khloe kardashian's mind is set that's
very true according to a source the
chances of the reality star getting back
together with her ex tristan thompson
slim to none it is what it is
a source tells et that while the
basketball pro wants to work things out
koko's current mindset once a player
always a player that's what everyone
says putting it simply the source adds
it would take a miracle for them to get
back together at this point
i'm someone who i do like to put my
relationships as a priority and i try to
make i really try to make that work
for now the 37 year old mom is focused
on the former couple's daughter
three-year-old true and their life
together
my favorite part about being a mom i
mean it's so corny but it's just like
no matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete bliss and just when
you see your baby and how happy and like
you just get through it and i was like
okay if i could do anything i could do
this and it's just the best and just the
love that you get that you also get to
give and receive it's just it's
beautiful another priority for the mama
is balancing a healthy co-parenting
relationship with tristan i think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style just weeks after admitting that he
fathered a child with fitness model
marylee nichols and issued a public
apology to chloe tristan all smiles
shared this adorable pic with little
true chloe hasn't spoken out about the
scandal but during tough times we know
she pays no mind to the drama it's just
i think a little too toxic for me to
keep reliving stuff like that so i stay
off social instead coco's hitting the
gym to detoxify multiple aspects of her
life
i love to work out and i love to just
like that's my selfish time khloe shared
this recent snap showing off her
impressive results
working out is one of my new obsession
healthy obsessions and she put her abs
on full display in this pic for her good
american apparel line
our source tells us chloe's been working
out with her sisters incessantly and
continuing to work on her revenge body
my revenge is not towards one person
it's more for
everyone who was so cruel to me
and
really shunned me i have revenge on that
and revenge almost on my old self it's
almost like in pretty woman when they
were like you can't afford that dress
big mistake
big mistake
big huge the source continues chloe's in
a great healthy space physically
mentally and spiritually quote she's
strongest when she's in a good workout
routine
but for coco she explained to et in 2019
it's about feeling good inside and
outside i really think i'm in a good
place but i think working on your
personal growth internally is something
that will be a forever
um mission and i always want to evolve
and grow and mature emotionally
because that's how we become better
people
[Music]